today if you spend no money on ads the
places where there's the most attention
and not as enough content to fill it
thus rendering your ability to reach a
lot more people is Tick Tock and
Linkedin one is very b2c and one is very
B2B it's really ironic you know we're
sitting in a moment of time and I have
not seen this in the last decade where
one mature platform and one extremely
young emerging platform are the current
state of organic reach at scale this is
just supply and demand it's always
supply and demand and yeah and this is
why the LinkedIn and Tick Tock
conversation so important because when
you don't have the luxury of big media
dollars you have to look for those
angles the reason that everybody should
make a tick tock video when you create
for the platform you may find a Nuance
there that you learn that three years
later matters for your business and
storytelling on a platform that does age
up and uses that Nuance the supply and
demand of attention moves on these
platforms The Tick Tock Arbitrage is
gonna close and it's going to close the
next 24 months and the land grab is
right now